n gualinga podría ser la creación verde
la amazonía con tan sólo 20 años lucha
por la justicia climática y por los
derechos de sus comunidades indígenas la
quechua sarayaku ubicada en el este
ecuatoriano y al hera tiene una voz cada
vez más internacional ella participó en
la cob 26 la cumbre climática más
importante organizada por la onu en
glasgow que se realizó el año pasado y
también ha estado en publicaciones
internacionales como la revista vogue
donde defendió la pintura facial de los
indígenas su hermana mina es otra joven
activista por los derechos ambientales
estas dos indígenas son de madre
ecuatoriana y de padre sueco en puyo el
corazón de la amazonía ecuatoriana
hablamos con elena y ella nos explicó
por qué considera que el gobierno
ecuatoriano de guillermo lasso no es tan
ambientalista como lo dice el presidente
bueno tenemos la expansión de la
frontera minera tenemos la extensión de
la frontera petrolera
solo una semana el presidente mismo
acabo de decir que quieren extraer hasta
la última gota de petróleo en la
amazonía hace unos meses antes igual
anunció que vamos a duplicar la cantidad
de petróleo que extraemos cada día
y ahorita el ecuador y los pozos
petroleros que tenemos no tienen la
capacidad de extraer esa cantidad de
petróleo entonces eso significa que
tenemos para poder conseguir esto el
estado ecuatoriano tiene que expandir la
frontera petrolera y eso no sabemos aquí
no nos va a afectar pero sabemos que eso
va a pasar en la amazonía y va a pasar
en los territorios indígenas y claro se
pinta de esta imagen verde y ecológica
afuera del país pero en realidad en los
territorios no es no es no es así
nosotros continuamos aquí en puyo
ecuador en la primera cumbre de
periodismo y cambio climático ustedes
sigan con nosotros